Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir Julie.
- Avez-vous été surprise de
cette décision vous vous
attendez a ça. Lecture n'est
jamais facile, pour l'avoir des
Q, on ne pense pasais
quand ça arrive, et là ça arrive
deux fois, pour les collègues
qui sont là cette décision,
c'est la bonne décM.
Coderre apprise. Je la laisse en
poser la Monsieur
Coderre vous avait notre fédéral
et au provincial, il a dit non,
non. Je ne me laisserai pas
tenter.  homme que la
politique dans le sang. Est-ce
qu'il peut se permettre de dire
jamais?
faut jamais dire jamais
mes fédéral connaît déjà.
Municipale il a fait. Souvent,
ce n'est pas un état d'esprit.
C'est sûr que maintenant,
aujourd'hui, après une défaite,a
un des affaires, se remémorer,
aussi c'est de trouver sa place.
Quand tu fais ça toute ta vie,
la politique, c'est que le
lendemain de la élections compta
locuteurs définissent,
découvrent qu'est-ce que tu
ferais comment tu vas le fai
Il aura besoin de cette pause,
allez voir ou lire après. De
peut-être faire autre chose
aussi. Ça va dépendre de ce
qu'il veut.
- Il y avait beaucion
dans ces points de presse. On a
vu les yeux se remplir d'eau. Il
a parlé avec elle. C'est dur.
Trouver ça dur la campagne
électorale. Il parlait de
l'homme réel derrière qui
encaissent les coups. Parfois je
me serais fâché, je me suis
retenu.  idée de
l'autre côté puis qu'on fait
simplement commenter puis
iciens, on n'a
pas idéal. Ça peut être
difficile.
- C'est extrêmement difficile.
J'ai fait cette campagne a titre
d'élu, je n'ai pas d'autres en
organisation. C'est dur. Less ée
dans une boule avec de la neige
dedans tu envies tout en
accéléré, toutes les émotions e.
Et tout s'arrête. Tous ceux qui
ont perdu leur élection, ce
n'est pas facile non plus.
L'occasion arrive pour se
redéfinir. Pour les nouveaux
collègues qui se joignent
l'équipe, c'est extrêmement
intéressant de comprendre et de
vivre la politique municipale en
état de la position. J'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir faire le
pouvoir, l'opposition et le
pouvoir. Permet de voir le côté
entre les lignes, de mieux
comprendre et quand vous allez
retrouver le pouvoir, d'être
encore mieux préparé pour
pouvoir gérer.
- Développer une sorte
d'expertise. La rencontre a été
très longue aujourd'hui. On est
dans les médias, on a entendu
des candidats qui ont perdu, qui
était en colère contre Monsieur
Coderre, qui ont dit que c'est
sa faute. Son erreur. C'est que
ces gens se parlent dans le
blanc des yeux aujourd'hui. Il y
en a qui avait des comptes a
réglé. Vous, vous avez déjà vécu
ce genre de rencontre post-
mortem. Comment ça se passe vers
les portes? Vous pensez que
c'est passé comme aujourd'hui.
- C'est ce que c'était le moment
où tout le monde se retrouvait.
Là, c'était vraiment le moment
où la famille se retrouvait. Ou
tous ces gens ont vécu la même
panoplie d'émotions.
L'adrénaline, la joie la
rapidité, la pression, les
émotions maximum. Aujourd'hui
c'est important pour eux de se
revoir. Toi, tu as perdu. C'est
vraiment un moment intense.
Ou déjà abordé ce qu'il pense,
ça va leur faire du bien. Chacun
le vit a sa façon, de façon
différente probablement. Le fait
de se revoir, c'est important.
- Déjà ça. Retrouver le sens de
l'équipe. Les candidats défaits
parfois vont prendre le cours de
leur vie rendue là. Parlons du
parti. Il n'y a pas de chef.
C'est quoi la suite du parti?
- Il y a deux bonnes personnes
qui étaient parties, des plus
vieilles au conseil municipal
qui maîtrisait l'ensemble des
dossiers. Il y a des nouveaux
qui arrivent. C'est bien ça
aussi. Ça fait du renouveau dans
les candidats. Il n'y a pas de
chef. Évidemment, ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'il était pour le
le temps de recul dans la
semaine prochaine puisse devrait
se faire par la suite. Certains
vont sentir ce qu'ils ont la
capacité pour y aller.
Ce n'est pas cette personne qui
va se présenter aux prochaines
élections, le chef de
l'opposition a un gros rôle a
joué, un peu comme l'opposition
de l'ensemble Montréal dans les
quatre dernières années. Ils ont
fait quand même un excellent
travail. La même dynamique va y
avoir. Une personne peut être le
chef, une femme et un homme les
autoportraits indiqués pour
défendre le dossier.
- Avec un parti en santé?
dans quel état elle partit
présentement.
- Je n'ai pas vu les chiffres.
Financièrement, le parti serait
en bonne situation ce qui permet
aux gens de pouvoir définir les
parties. C'est le temps, que ma
ces crise, les opportunités.
C'est l'opportunité de se
réinventer. Se redéfinir, de
rechausser les priorités, de
décider comment on peut être
parti aux années 2021 avec les
nouveaux besoins ils ont une
occasion importante de le faire
maintenant. Et pour les quatre
prochaines années. C'est comme
un phénix qui va renaître de ses
cendres. Le parti encore cette
occasion. Je crois parce qu'ils
ont l'occasion de faire tous ces
changements.
- Tourner ces pages vite en
politique regarder en avant et
découvre